brasil parece no ver la luz al final del
túnel ningún otro país de américa
registra tantos contagios como esta
nación el miércoles se contabilizaron
más de 90 mil casos en las últimas 48
horas hubo más de 5 mil fallecidos
además preocupa la ocupación
hospitalaria y aunque el presidente de
jair bolsonaro sigue insistiendo en no
respetar el distanciamiento social su
designado un nuevo ministro de salud
parece tener otro mensaje
podemos reducir el impacto de los
fallecidos con dos puntos primero con
políticas de distanciamiento social que
permitan una reducción de la circulación
del virus y segundo con una mejoría en
la capacidad de asistencia de nuestros
servicios hospitalarios y sial los
nuevos servicios hospitalarios el país
vecino colombia registra en contraste
cifras diarias a la baja de contagios y
fallecidos y ahora con un aliciente en
su plan de vacunación el miércoles se
alcanzó el millón de inoculaciones
todos como equipo estamos demostrando
que la vacunación masiva es la mejor
política de la vida en estos momentos de
pandemia a nivel regional chile es el
país que lidera las vacunaciones con más
del 25 por ciento de su población con al
menos una dosis aplicada pero la
ocupación de las ucis hace saltar las
alarmas
ahora mismo hay más de 3000 de estas
camas ocupadas la cifra más alta en toda
la pandemia hay que mantenerse alerta y
desde perú lo refrendan el gobierno
anunció la prohibición de los viajes por
tierra y aire para los próximos días
festivos entre el 1 y el 4 de abril en
semana santa para frenar una pandemia
que en este territorio deja cerca de
50.000 muertos y casi un millón y medio
de contagios